the biden white house is jubilant over
its infrastructure framework calling it
historic
so why the 17 republicans who voted to
advance the bill
throwing biden a lifeline here now is
one of those
17 republican senator lindsey graham
senator this is a trillion dollar bill
at a time we're facing massive inflation
other pressures and
president trump said you guys have made
a terrible deal that republicans are big
losers here
and that the democrats are the big
winners so why is he wrong
i think he's wrong because he had a bill
for 1.7 trillion dollars
infrastructure spending which i
supported we could never get it done
this is 12 1.2 trillion for roads
bridges and ports
and if you don't think we've got a road
bridge and port problem you're not
looking at america the way it
is the three and a half trillion dollar
bill they want to follow along with is
socialism
but count me in for road bridges and
ports paid for i understand what i'm for
and i understand what i'm against and i
think
it's the same economy structure bill you
think this is the same economy as it was
when president trump was
was in office that inflationary
pressures that we're seeing today
have no effect on the spending and that
this is not a glide path to make
at least three trillion dollars of
spending possible it gives a huge win to
the white house they're thrilled
yeah yeah i really don't believe that at
all was about me
we're spending the money in the out
years it's de-inflationary we're putting
money
aside for an eight-year road bridge port
plan to upgrade
what i just said that doesn't create
inflation where crete's inflation is a
three and a half trillion dollar bill
big government spending with tax
increases i don't know we'll see
i see men you differ on this i think
america needs infrastructure i'm for and
i think america doesn't need socialism
i'm against it but why didn't you know
senators
but senator why didn't you do it pelosi
played hardball and you guys rolled over
why didn't you say we'll vote on
infrastructure once you show your hand
on the 3.5 trillion
why are we giving the the leverage to
the democrats
on the process pelosi is like we're not
doing that we're doing it the other way
and you guys are like okay
we'll just do the infrastructure first
yeah i think you nailed something so
follow this it's going to pass the
senate
uh with what democratic and republican
support the 3.5 trillion dollar bill
won't get any republican support what
does nancy pelosi do
does she hold that bipartisan bill
hostage does she get
the until she gets to three and a half
trillion dollar socialist wish list
good luck with that nancy she's going to
merge the two bills
and i think it collapses in the house
and it'll be a shame if we can't do
something good for america because she
wants three and a half trillion dollars
to socialize the country we'll see how
this plays out in the house
but you so you think the order of these
bills
was correct doing the infrastructure
first
and then letting them tackle the 3.5
trillion which
she said that's not going to fly but
okay well in the senate i think i think
cinema and mansion are going to be less
likely to do three and a half trillion
dollar bill
if we can do a bipartisan bill for tree
and dedicated to real infrastructure
we'll see how that plays out i think
nancy pelosi is making a big mistake
she's going to insist that the socialist
bill pass
first good luck with that and she's
going to throw the bipartisan bill over
and hold it hostage and i hope kevin
mccarthy
will hold the troops and say we're not
going to play that game
all right senator we hope but uh we hope
it works out that way i don't i don't
think john cena
is going to get it i don't think he's
going to be standing up against anything
here but thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else